I think this emote is going to be very popular.
It's found by trading a homeward bone with pickle pee or pump a rum the crows.
Whose nest is found at the top of Firelink Shrine after you buy the tower key from the Hand Maiden
As always, there is this huge list of shiny items that you can trade by dropping one at a time,
and I'll throw a list of all the currently known ones in the description.
The most notable ones though are Lucatiel's mask, emotes, a lightning gem, and the shiniest reward of all.
While you're up in the rafters, grab that estus shard and then walk to the far end and hit the wall
It's an illusory one. There are so many of these in Dark Souls 3.
Behind it is the Covetous Silver Serpent Ring, which increases souls dropped by around 10 percent.
Number 3
is that the Estus shard, and nest, and the ring, is all accessible early without the towerkey
via this jumping shortcut off the tree.
Face the roof, run diagonally up the tree and then do a diagonal right while pressing L3 (jump)
If you are having trouble making the jump, don't worry, you're probably not bad
It's just more than likely that it's been patched since this video came out.
So, no one tell Miyazaki
Number 4
In Lothric, you would have met a woman named Emma in the cathedral.
If you kill her, then it initiates one of the major endgame bossfights early
which leads to an endgame area if you can kill the boss,
and it's a pretty big "IF"
because The Dancer is tough.
Killing her legitimately at around soul level 35 was by far the hardest thing I've done in this game,
and I've finished it a few times now.
However, if you do it, then the rewards are pretty damn good,
especially if you're running a Faith or a Strength build
because there are a lot of Miracles and strength weapons in Upper Lothric Castle.
Here's a short list of what you can get
Now, there is a way to cheese The Dancer and kill her easily on any character,
but it's probably gonna get patched soon. I'll tell you about it later in this upcoming video instead.
Number 5
So, fast forwarding to the Undead Settlement. There's this really secret covenant
that you can join, but you have to do it before killing The Cursed Greatwood.
Turn right at the burning tree, go across the bridge and then go around the right side of the building, through these barrels.
Climb the ladder and run along the rooftops to the right. Below, you will see a cage carrier,
but as long as you haven't killed the Cursed Greatwood, he's non-hostile.
So, walk up behind him and, ya know, do the logical thing, and climb into his cage, get thrown down into a pit,
crawl out of your cage, and talk to Hodric to join the Mound Maker's covenant.
Mound Makers drop a white or red sign, but it appears purple.
So, if someone summons you with this sign, then you can either kill the enemies in their world and help them,
or you can kill the host or their phantom for the reward.
Alright, between us, here is what we're gonna do.
When the game first comes out, no one's going to know what these purple signs do.
So, put on a white summon ring that you get from Yuria,
get summoned into someone's world, and just
kill all the enemies, help them out, and be friendly, wave at them
and then, once you've gained their trust
turn on them, when the time is right, backstab them when their health is low, or something like that
Eventually, you'll get 10 Vertebrae Shackles, and these can be handed in for a new katana
called Bloodlust, which I've heard is good
or 30 shackles rewards you with the Warmth spell
nr. 6
when i first uploaded this video, i said that you had to offer the Young White Branch to the giant
in order to gain his friendship
but apparently, this isn't true
though, Koyzish, in the comments, said that he doesn't fire upon you
if you start with the White Branch starting gift, which I confirmed and that's atleast somewhat interresting, right?
anyway, in this reuploaded video, enjoy the fact that you can do emotes at the firekeeper
and get a response, exciting, huh?
nr. 7
Did you know that some enemies are ridiculously weak to fire?
for example, dogs, tree hollows, both of those will writhe on the ground if you hit them with any fire damage at all
which, pretty much guarantees you a kill after the first hit
the best example of this though, are those maggot monsters
who are completely incapacitated by fire
so pull out the torch every time you face against them
without this knowledge of fire, they are really tough
because they cover you in maggots, and your bleed meter will rise for a ridiculous stretch of time
but don't worry, if you do get covered in maggots, simply pull out your torch and they'll fly off
nr. 8
In Farron Swamp, if you follow the left wall as soon as you enter the swamp
you'll eventually come across these three tree monsters
and after dealing with the bullshit of the swamp, I bet most of you just ignored them
well, if you kill them, one of them drops the Black Bow of Pharris
which is one of the best ranged weapons
and also Pharris' cap
nr. 9
before Farron Swamp, is the Crucifixion Woods
where you'll experience your first NPC invasion, from Yellowfinger, if you're in Ember Form
Kill him, and he'll drop the Xanthous helm and Heysel pick
and this is a recurring theme thorough the games, so if you're someone who wants to hunt down every weapon
make sure embered at least once in every area and you'll get invaded, and you'll have NPCs to kill for their weapons
nr. 10
speaking of killing, if you're wondering what NPCs drop
don't worry
I've sacrificed one of my characters and made him go on a murdering spree, to find out
Anri drops her Luck scaling Straight Sword
Horace drops a shield with really balansed defenses
Cornyx the pyromancer, gives his awesome looking set
Eygon drops his weapon and his shield
Irina drop the towerkey
the giant drops the Hawk Ring
Siegward drops the Storm Ruler, the Pierce Shield and the Catarina Set
Sirris drops her talisman
Yuria drops Darkdrift, the invisible katana
Leonhard drops his hat
and Patches drops his spear and his ring
Most of the NPCs I've named also drops their ashes
which gives you access to a bunch of their armor sets at the Handmaiden, if you didn't know
And if you're wondering where to find these NPCs, and how to initiate all the questlines
Subscribe, because i'm going to be putting out a video this week, with all of that info
Because the first time i played Dark Souls 3
I missed so many quest lines and you should be able to catch them all, if you watch that video
But to finish, one more thing
which is bit more of a challenge to you guys
I wanted to put this in as a secret, but couldn't figure it out
So, in the Undead Settlement, past the ladder we climbed earlier to get to the Mound Maker's covenant
There's this NPC who is a friendly undead conglomerate
I cannot figure out what this guy is on about
And I can't figure out his purpose
Do you have any idea?
My best guess, is that he is giving you a hint
That you are supposed to climb into the guy's cage nearby
But, goddamn, that's Fromsoft's idea of a hint, apparently
Thank you for watching guys
and I hope you learned something new
Also, I wanted to give a huge shout out to a Russian Souls uploader, named Will Max
He's been doing the russian captions for all the recent videos
And he was the one who reminded me to enable that setting, in the first place
which allows people to contribute their own captions, so do me a favor and check out his channel
And, since I've enabled it, i've had contributions people who speak portugese, chinese contributors
and, if you know a language other than english, and you feel like captioning some videos
I'd be so thankful if you could do that, it means I can talk to a wider audience
So yeah, I'd appreciate that, and thank you for watching
I'll see you in the next one.